honestly
i i
i don't excuse the
muslim youth from committing zinna
they are
in all the muslim countries the sin is
on the rise
people want to say you guys are talking
smack you always want to get you know
your videos liked and this and that it's
not really happening with all the
respect you have no clue what the heck
you're talking about like today you and
i saw
what the heck is going on right
you saw it
so you can dream as much as you want you
can sit in your corner crawl in some
hole and whatever and just chill that's
fine
but reality is reality it's gonna bite
you in the back one day because when you
ignore and you choose to ignore that
these things are real then you choose to
target people say you guys talk always
about this negative you're toxic blah
blah
it passes in front of you don't
recognize it and when you f when it
finally comes to bite you oh i didn't
know that this oh i need to repent i
need to change oh it's too late
it's too late
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
what is our exact location
this is called the medieval
there's a mountain across the mountain
it's an old village
an ancient civilization actually
and it's maintained the name
and it's where the sand meets the
mountain this is called fossil rock
welcome back to the realest podcast in
the dunya the three muslims
the two muslims man the two muslims for
the first time in our entire year of
youtube or finally in person
would you like to tell uh the viewers
what this undisclosed location is
or would that no longer be undisclosed
exactly okay
bismillah so first thing on my mind
how about we let them guess in the
comments section inshallah uh
first thing i want to talk about today
haram relationships all right
being in the in the field having skin in
the game why do you think this is an
issue today where do you think this
stems from there's an epidemic
everyone's just they're doing things
where they think it's halal dating does
that even exist
relationships are easy
and human beings
we're hedonists you know we love to
to feed the
the body
and
it is part of human nature that you want
to be intimate
and you know people think it's just
about sex
it goes beyond it's about having someone
next to you
a lot of for example couples think okay
i didn't actually have intercourse i'm
just hugging and kissing and sleeping in
the same body we didn't do it
but that itself is still hard
they have the need to just
be close to someone touch someone
right and as we know the process him
said that i rather have a nail driven to
my head than to touch the hand of a
foreign woman
right
so
people still holding hands kissing
hugging moving around dating so we're
not doing haram we're just we're just
dating
it's been
sold to us
through media culture and so on that
this is something that
you should do you can you need to get to
know each other
and
on the other side you have
the other options are
very very uh slim today to find so it's
very difficult okay someone will hook
you up auntie uncle
but a lot of times
the youth today when they're watching
constantly these shows these
tocks instagrams people you know loving
each other and true love and
wow we married for love right they they
want that
but of course that's not reality it's
it's it's it's fake it's fairy tale
fairy tale they want that now look there
will be
one in a hundred one thousand yeah they
might it might happen no that people
right away fall in love at love at first
sight or whatever i'm not saying it
doesn't happen
but
everyone it's being pushed on us through
these
social media platforms so everyone wants
that they're longing for it so when
auntie comes says yeah i know we have to
get to it no
see someone a couple of questions then
you get married mm-hmm a lot be like no
i want to get to know this person mm-hmm
i want to feel that whether it's drop
down test drive i wanna i wanna i wanna
so
it's it's a huge issue because
it's in line with our desires bro
and anything that's in line with our
desires it's easy to to follow it's it's
the easiest and that's why in islam
submission purification heart is against
your desires
right it's always the other way around
right now you still have the ability to
satisfy your desires
in halal
but
that's one avenue
only
while the other avenues the haram are
many how many right
says in the quran don't go near zena
why do you think allah said don't go
near zuna
well
zinna
is
people
think that okay well i'm going to be
there i'm just going to say no i'm not
going to do it
but the reality is
that you don't know that
we look at yusef al-islam
and the story
and
he's a prophet
and he himself said that all life you do
not protect me i'll feel inclined to
what they call me
right
and
seven people be shared on the lustrous
one of them is a man a young man was
being called by a woman of beauty and
status and he says i fear allah it's
it's it's
you know when you're there you guys oh
i'm not gonna do it
but when if you get there to that point
it might be the point of no return
it might be the point of narrative i
mean let's honestly say how many
how many people can honestly say
let's be like let's real talk you know
let's say you're with the woman
and it can't happen
and
you're in a enclosed area
and you thought no i'm not gonna do i'm
just gonna i'm just going to talk to her
so it starts with i'm just going to talk
to
i'm just going to sit with her i'm just
going to hold her hand i'm just going to
kiss her i'm just going to take off her
shirt how many people can from that
point really resist i mean honestly
let's be honest i mean you guys can also
say be honest with yourself would you be
able to resist a very extremely
beautiful woman or if you're a woman a
man an attractive man
to be able to resist that temptation
we're not we're not asking do you want
to be able to resist right will you
really be able to resist if you ask
yourself this unadulterated question
most of you wouldn't
yeah so so it's that's why allah says
don't come close to it don't put
yourself in the situation
because you might not it might be the
point of no return
and
that's how the scholar said that the
pain
of having patience with
you know there is pain bro when you
desire someone like and you're not
having you're like
right
but he said that pain is lesser than the
pain of regret of the sin you know
right and you know that like
and i think i want to add to that is
that
i think the worst part is when
that pain disappears after you do it two
three four or five times and it gets to
it and you don't even have that anymore
and you're done you just
your heart is gone and you're just
on it and you don't feel anything
anymore
then you're gone i feel like at that
point once you start sinning and falling
into the trap of zinna
you fall into this and you mention this
in a lot of videos you make
alhamdulillah that you have a new way of
life that no longer fits islamic
paradigm so to not feel guilty now
you could either fix your life to fit
the islamic paradigm again but most
people don't they change their paradigm
now yeah because islam now becomes the
problem of allah because this is the
thing that's making me feel guilty
exactly why do i need this islam thing
to make me feel guilty
if what i'm doing isn't even so bad if
everyone's doing it so let me just
get rid of this assumption for allah
and then i no longer have to feel this
guilty feeling anymore no i mean the
objective shaytan is not to to make you
commit sins
is to make you commit kufr the sins are
the steps
right
and don't follow the steps of shaytan so
these sins are steps but the main
objective is for you to fall into
into
kufur and that's why i remember one of
the
stories
of the scholars they said there was a
man
who fell in love with this girl this
non-muslim girl
he was summoning the sham or something
and he really wanted her
and like he followed her to the house
and they were doing all kinds of weird
stuff
and you know she wanted to marry her and
she like gave him alcohol to drink and
he was acting foolish and i just wonder
he says look you cannot have me unless
you
uh renounce islam
he said okay arnold's islam just scared
me okay okay he just jumped somewhere
climb on the table or someone just fell
and broke his neck
and died as as a
and then there's another story smiling
let's give the other side
where
one
man was able to get past the point of
return so we pray
to allah you shouldn't be in that
situation but
it can happen
so
they say that this was a man that
smelled like musk all the time
and i guess what happened is he he was
in a predicament where
he ended up in the house of a woman she
seduced him
to come to her for whatever reason i
cannot remember exactly
and she literally appeared to him naked
and she was extremely beautiful right so
the guy couldn't they didn't know what
to do
and he's okay give me just a couple i
need to go to the bathroom so he went to
the washroom and at that time you know
the way that he took poop and put it all
over his body
and he walked out so when the woman saw
him the way it smells she starts
screaming and cursing and kicked him out
and ran out she wasn't in that yeah just
between us she wasn't into that yeah
yeah she didn't like that it's not like
a fetish you know it wasn't embarrassing
but today there's a feminist yeah that's
why you're asking some people you're
right
so we're making it clear that it wasn't
but then they said that his skin would
always smell like musk after that
you know allah gave him what's called
the
or almost like a miracle
where his skin was just smelling like
musk because
he did that for the sake of allah he
feared allah he found himself in that
situation but then he did something
drastic to to get out of it but how many
people could do that i mean how many
people would put poop on themselves
there
really come on
i mean it's like but it's the story of
the ancient like of the scholars
so it's not like a lot of times there's
these extreme examples used just to show
like the the magnitude of the the
they're real though these are real
real stories of the of the salaf you
know not
assuming that this whole thing of
halal dating is widespread which is i
hear so many people saying you know
we're boyfriend we don't do anything
though we're just we're just together
and i'm just like what does this even
mean all right so
these boundaries that people are playing
with
what is
what is the limit like what at what
point does it become
zena because a lot of people think that
zina is just intercourse it's not
intercourse it's not the eyes does it
have that hair is the hand so
at what point should people refrain from
when is a good boundary to
not cross or ever you know
overcome when you're looking to get
married with someone
well i think
um
you feel it when you're hiding and you
don't want people to know what you're
doing
that's kind of like what the process and
that's that's a that's a sin and come on
we all know what we're talking about
everyone's got their secret
handshakes with the with the shaytan
let's and for lack of better words so i
think everyone knows what i'm talking
about i'm not saying that you're doing
this
but i'm sure that once in your life you
had something that you didn't want
someone around you to know or to find
out
and the way you felt about it right it's
kind of like that without dating as well
as you you don't walk out on the street
and
be like this my wife you know just
someone or is my girlfriend because
you're like you always like watching
your back and why not because you know
that it's wrong you can call it whatever
you want in the end your heart tells you
that it's wrong
but then again the more you do it the
less you will feel it right so you might
lose that
that that feeling
so
yeah the halal dating there's no such
thing as hell dating there is taaroof
yes you can get to know and i think
again
yeah we can talk about problems but what
are the solutions right the muslim
community is still far behind and
offering
halal solutions now that doesn't excuse
the people from committing i mean for
committing sins
we're not saying that
but there's accountability on all sides
are are the leaders of our communities
solving these problems
are they being held accountable
like okay you're making videos and doing
lectures
great
but what are the outcomes of those
lectures because the process and didn't
didn't just what we call say and i'm not
trying to push anyone down but it's
kalan
just talk
there was
an objective and when allah says
it's a communication
to human beings meaning it's requiring
something from you honestly
i i
i don't excuse the
muslim youth from committing zina
they are
in all the muslim countries the sin is
on the rise
people want to say you guys are talking
smack you always want to get you know
your videos liked and this and that it's
not really happening with all the
respect you have no clue what the heck
you're talking about like today you and
i saw
what the heck is going on right
you saw it
so
you can dream as much as you want you
can sit in your corner crawl in some
hole and whatever and just chill that's
fine
but reality is reality it's going to
bite you in the back one day
because when you ignore and you choose
to ignore that these things are real
then you choose to target people say you
guys talk always about this negative
you're toxic blah
it passes in front of you don't
recognize it and when you f when it
finally comes to bite you're going oh i
didn't know that this oh i need to
repent i need to change oh it's too late
it's too late
so
yes it's a problem but what can we do
about it what are the
systems what are the
solutions
to these problems we talked about okay
fine some people don't even talk about
it which is horrible
but where where where are the the actual
practical because see
in the sharia if you offer someone
halal
so even like the sharia right
it if a thief steals because he's hungry
because the system didn't provide enough
food or opportunities for work
then the qadhi might excuse him and not
punish him
okay
yes
but if there's plenty of things
everything's fine the system is there
and the person insists on stealing and
now it's a crime
it's not driven by need when it's driven
by need omar khattab during the drought
didn't punish the people or steal and
then cut their hands off
because he
held himself accountable for not being
able to provide what he is supposed to
provide
now the question is in our communities
we need to ask ourselves before we point
fingers do are we providing halal
avenues
then you can really come hard down on
people
because when you have a halal option and
haram you're still choosing the haram
there's you messed up
you're a criminal when you have sugar
and poop and you're choosing poop over
sugar
you know you've got a problem you're a
dirty boy
it's like halal meat and haram meat
right
good healthy meat and spoiled meat
there's something wrong with you so in
an islamic sharia system
the sharia system makes sure it offers
ability for youth to get married job
opportunities
zakah
or like help to get married right
financial help even to pay the maha
there are even this muslim country
example there is
something like that
where youth are helped
so they have no excuse to really commit
zuna because actually it's quite easy to
get married they pay for this and this
and they give you a loan for a house
without interest and they give you the
land and all these things really this is
a reality what's your excuse to go and
take a hooker on the street which is
you know why why commit zina when you
are being provided with all the
opportunities and more to get married
and you don't want one take two if you
don't like ten two take three you know
one day three take four
and you have the ability and they will
help you with all in all cases to
control to achieve this you know
let me play shaytan's advocate right now
for a lot of people that are probably
here wondering okay
cool it can do that but isn't a
relationship or a long-term relationship
the same as a marriage as a nikah
because they might say 1400 years ago
there was no ltr a long-term
relationship there was either zina
widespread or marriage so this whole
long-term relationship
it kind of really is the same as a
marriage yes we don't have
a shaykh
and we don't have the wali we don't the
hijab we don't the maha but isn't it
really the same thing what really is the
difference between a marriage and a
long-term relationship very simple it's
it's a an issue of
just a couple things as a as the hadith
prophet said the difference between
hilal and haram
is two witnesses and the maha and the
wali
that's it
that's what he said that's what the
brown system said
so
that's it it's yeah you can say like
what's the difference between an islamic
clone
and uh rebel right people say well
there's interest in this and that yeah
but even in islamic law some scholars
say you can have a profit rate but it's
different
so some people can i mean you're gonna
a lot of muslims say today you have i'm
not gonna go now into because i know a
lot of people say no but islamic banks
are this and that
fine
but in the end you have
an islamic bank that has a sharia board
that has some scholars who be held
accountable
and who are telling that we know and we
endorse this allah says
ask the people of knowledge if you don't
know so you've done your best as a
normal muslim to just ask the scholars
the scholar said it's it's halal
and then you have on the other side the
a lot of prophet
say no no they have no clue about what
is the process of the islamic bank and
this and again i'm not going to go into
the haram just give us an example but on
the end on the day of judgement
allah will ask you like you had an
islamic bank and all you had to even if
the scholar was wrong even if that
islamic bank was wrong
and was making a mistake and it's still
like ribba
but
you all you had to do is go to the
scholar the one who knows and it would
have been on him
the accountability would be for you all
you need to do is just take the
correctness yeah
but you just decided to go for proper
riba interest contract clear cut
ambiguous changing depending on
inflation tata and you wanted that
because you said oh you chose that you
chose that and you say oh islamic banks
are the same bro you don't know you have
no clue exactly but you made a willing
choice to go so the same thing you know
i want a long-term relationship because
the same way you think is the same in
marriage
but like like
okay
a lot of the butchers cut the throat
because a lot of people say the blood
has to drain and they're not
well yeah but most you have to say
bismillah allah you know you have to
follow
so it's a simple it's just saying a few
words and it makes the food halal what
there's something you know some people
try to explain like oh something happens
in the body of the chicken and this and
that bro does that happen no you just
said bismillah he just slaughtered it
and the other guy next to you he didn't
say bismillah he still slaughtered it
even if his face in mecca even if he's a
muslim it's not halal facts so it's it's
it's an issue of uh you know just
saying a few words and the nikah same
thing it's a few words few people
present offering and done
i would even go as far as to say the
nikka getting islamically married to a
woman if you're a man and vice versa
it's less risky and you have less to
lose than a long-term relationship
because if you get into a long-term
sorry if you get into a
religion a religious islamic
institutional marriage
if it doesn't work out divorce is
permissible right there's nothing wrong
with it there's no
you know this is the same christianity
guys till death do us a part right
there's not going to be you know
never divorce no right there was
if it's you know a marriage you never
sin
it doesn't work out allah if it works
alhamdulillah
long-term relationship if it doesn't
work out oh now you you're addicted to a
person
that you can't be with that you weren't
with all right now you got to carry this
on for the rest of your life if you're a
woman it's going to affect you if you're
mad it's also going to affect you
there's studies to show women are
psychologically more affected by the
number of partners they have than men um
this can be proven by the fact that
in islam men can have multiple partners
permissibly women can't this is another
discussion we're not going to get into
that because a lot of women are like oh
why can um you know a woman not have
four husbands because i can't allah says
because allah you want you want a lot of
reasons that's a separate video yeah
we'll make another video one day i'll
give you one reason right now uh
a surety of uh paternity
right
as men and a lot of sisters they're not
gonna like this now that i mentioned
this but
here's here's the cold hard truth for
y'all
we as men we will never guarantee that
a child is our child we can
a woman biologically
has a has a baby growing in her for nine
months as soon as she gives birth she
knows that's hers 50 of the genes has to
be hers
however if she has four husbands let's
say how will any of those men know that
it's his son or daughter they can
men will never have that guarantee
however if a man has four wives all of
those women know they have a surety of
maternity
people can say they can do tests but
that's not what we're talking about
we're talking like you know imagine
you're going back i want to check with
this my child or not my mom man that's
it can't happen but we're talking about
just in a relationship
right like did you take a paternity test
did you take him a turn did you no you
didn't right
yeah you can if you're going to
you know investigate something but
that's not what we're talking about
talking about how a person feels a man
knows that's much or the woman knows
this is my child
it's in my womb you know what i mean
that's it for the man
could be could not do do you think
there's a level in haram relationships
people that are like justifying well i'm
just going to be you know i see a lot of
kofan i've been with my chick for nine
years 10 years oh why aren't you just
together oh you know
we're just waiting you know
do you think there's a level of
commitment that's not there
well i think we're living in
a time where
commitment
on all levels is all-time low but be a
marriage be it work
be it parenting parenting health
whatever it is we are living in this
mediocre
uh world where people are not given
their best there's no commitment
and that's
that's affecting us on all level people
are not trying their best anymore
because they're they're weak they have
excuses
they blame people
it's it's you know life is not what i
want it to be everyone's got a an ideal
again influenced by what they see this
fake
social media that is conditioning and
thinking this is the dream life i want
and you're not gonna get it trust me
that you won't get what you're seeing on
tick tock
because what's on tick tock is fake
okay
these people are sitting there have you
ever seen someone recording a tick tock
video it's not like this
people need to arrange and make sure
everything
you know it's like it's fake it's not
organic
you know
you're trying to put on a show
you see the 60 seconds of the tick tock
reel but you don't see the hours put in
behind just to make it look perfect and
in a certain way you know you see these
like vacation videos it looks so amazing
you're not there for the rest of the 23
point you know
23 hours and
59. you know five minutes
to see how the couple reacts to what
they're doing whether they're on each
other's case they're really lovey-dovey
like the way you see it in these 20
seconds or not come on or how was the
trip all the way there the tiredness the
fights that they had all you see is this
little
bite of
of information from and i think that's
the problem right everything is fast
knowledge is fast
uh
i'm sorry this is fast because
everything is just
fast fast food is fast fast food breeds
everything is fast
and
swipe and we like there's no more
time no more value no more sitting there
and actually
you know putting in the time and i think
that's that's killing us
okay
this being said i i do want to talk
about what an islamic marriage actually
is because a lot of people think it's
some complicated thing where you need to
go to masjid and it needs to be an event
a lot of witnesses it's not anything
complicated but before that i want to
touch on a topic a lot of people i don't
want to say the m word because it might
get demonetized but a lot of people
think that pleasing oneself
is better than zina because at least i'm
not
with someone else you know at least i'm
not doing any you know sin with someone
else at least it's just me what are your
thoughts on that
i mean again um
people say taking the lesser of two
evils it is a concept in islam
if you're going to commit zina
let's call it but it doesn't mean that
it's not haram
but you know you start getting into this
habit of always taking the lesser of two
evils
and it becomes a
default
like you're not striving for doing the
right thing anymore
you're striving for doing this wrong
thing the less wrong thing right so this
is not a good mentality to to be in
but okay many it's a huge problem it's
encouraged it comes under
self-love they use these kind nice words
self-pleasure uh
hell health
right it comes under the tag of health
and personal health
and self-exploration safe exploration
which are very like wow really and uh
yeah you get you get used to that and
after 10 years of that and delaying
marriage you're finally put up face to
face with someone to live with them and
be intimate not working the way i
thought it would well yeah because
you've been doing yourself for 10 years
of course you're not gonna work the same
way man
imagine you know
if i do something for 10 years i perfect
it no doubt about it and then i expect
someone else to do it the same way i do
it
proper islamic marriage let's forget
proper just the basic halal permissible
islamic marriage real quick
how is that done like why is it
something that people think it's
confusing we already talked about it but
is it actually something that simple is
this something that just can be done in
like five minutes what is it well i
think we need to go back again to the
sun and brussels
of course people use that time argument
oh it's not the same time and
right but it's literally
people think you need a shaykh and this
now again
people will
raise flags here red flags and see yeah
but people can cheat you see if you're
always thinking from the mindset of
uh people are thieves and people are bad
and people cheat you
then yeah of course
you're going to live in a world of
criminals everyone's a criminal even
before doing anything
are there criminals in this world have
them be men who have abused marriages
and have used this the simplicity of the
nikah yes
no doubt about but that does that
invalidate the process no it doesn't you
cannot change the process just because
some people
have used
the
simplicity of the nikah for their own
advantage okay just like you can't judge
islam because of muslims exactly but
nothing in islam can can be done like
that
you cannot
say well you know i'm going to
invalidate yes there's a concept in
sharia called siddha dera to stop the
means if it can lead to harm
okay
but
so let's say for example there's
something halal
but people are exploiting it
and
the kadhi or the judge or the ruler can
say i'm going to stop this halal thing
because people are just messing around
with it
right that can happen but
the reality is that
the outcome should be positive but we've
seen that the outcome is negative
because zina is increasing it's not like
okay
why did people
in many muslim countries stop pollution
or discourage it
and even marriage is because people have
not married properly they've messed
around they've done all kinds of things
been a lot of weird stuff happening
right some people said we'll stop it
let's go against it
but the outcome was not positive it's
negative
even in the muslim countries that have
for example
outlawed polygyny there are some they're
not allowed to talk
zinna's on the rise
you supposedly they or the intention was
to stop this men who are just uh
tourists you know just playing okay fine
good intention but look at the outcome
zina's on the rise like crazy because
marriage has become so difficult
uh women is also single politician you
forget about it can get arrested men are
committing politicians they're doing
polish anyway but illegally or
unlawfully let's say
and uh
it's still there man you cannot make a
fish be a horse and it's just men are by
nature like that
they will still do it even if they tell
you they don't even if they're gonna uh
fight for your right and be
foot to full shoulder with you against
the this issue
in the end
tomorrow will be somewhere else 100
see men and women
in islam and men and women in in the
kofal they're different they're too
different yeah
psychologically spiritually emotionally
sexually whatever you want to call it in
islam and in the kofad there's a lot of
parallels see in the disbelievers they
have side things they have a work wife
they have the the chick the he texts
they have the actual wife they have the
girlfriend
the the
one he probably hires there's so many
yeah
and in islam we have wives now a lot of
people think that having multiple wives
is the same as having multiple
girlfriends or side things no no there's
there's a lot of the huge differences
between the two
stuff like responsibility what are some
of these differences like people think
that they're actually the same
there's a huge difference a big big
difference
and
marriage is about building
a family even if you don't have children
people think it's about having children
no it's about building a family a unit a
unit
that is the building block of the ummah
okay and that comes with the blessings
of allah with the barakah
with the responsibilities the gender
roles there's a manual of operation
standard operating procedures
it might sound dry but it is what it is
and that those sops
help
things
move forward help things work well
help the umma to grow
and when you don't do it like that then
you don't have that it's the opposite
effect so yeah the differences are huge
commitment wise people say i'm committed
but i'm not yeah but it's not the same
you're committed in front of allah first
and foremost before in front of that
person that's the big thing in islam
right it's it's in front of allah
because you can the person might feel
like you're the most committed to them
but you're cheating on them
but when you know that allah is watching
you're committed to allah first you
can't man even if that person is not
there no one's saying you're traveling
you're doing whatever you're not going
to do that because of what because the
person is not there or because you know
it's because you're committed to allah
you know what i mean 100 so that's kind
of you know i mean you can talk a lot
about that but that's the main thing
it's always
allah comes first for a muslim
so marriage is for the sake of allah
families for the sake of allah provision
is for the sake of allah stability is
for sake of all love is for the sake of
allah everything is for sick of allah oh
people why why why everything because he
is the one
who is the author of love who is the
author of safety was the author of
provision was the author of all these
things
so you have to
and and guys anyone watching this like
the reason we we push islam and nika
is it's kind of difficult to
measure
kofar love disbelievers what they do
because if someone says
i was talking about uh with you about
this a month ago um on the phone like if
somebody in in like
non-muslims they say oh i love you baby
don't worry i love you how do you
measure that bro but a neca in a way
really is a contract in a way it's
measurable there's things there's
responsibility yes there's rights but
there's duties there's responsibilities
it's not just oh i love you babe so
please believe me and we can be together
and you know live in this fairy tale no
there's responsibilities i can track if
you're doing your end of the bargain
that's it all right
that's it
so okay with that being said
uh smash that like button guys more
episodes in person inshallah
boom uh maybe do you think they've
finally earned your uh
you know for you to reveal the
undisclosed location yet or let them
guess it
okay no worries okay bismillah then okay
guys with that being said
until next time
gabriel ended up bismuth
forgot to be like what do you guys
usually say
just dua
yo what's your favorite meal here bro
inshallah
okay a desert flower look at that
any proper purple
anyhow look
this
photosynthesis happening here that's
true
look at
this dead
[Music]
bro this is like therapy
who needs a psychiatrist bro i love to
come here bro
fridays after the hot buzz or whatever
is to finish in dubai just drive back
and stop here
right here
so no gps
that's crazy because y'all know how like
impactful it was yeah isn't it if you're
watching this it was so
it was such a strong dream
that i woke up
and then i was talking to my dad and i
was crying
because i was strong the dream was how
impactful the dream was
and then i ended up driving to uh the
mosque it was like 5 40 something
to do fajr at the mosque and i was
crying the entire way to the mosque
and subhanallah i think it's crazy that
um
[Music]
[Music]
hmm